okay so the moonlight trailer is
something special and piecing it all
together is like solving a rubik's cube
that's constantly rotating as oscar
isaac's mark specter jumps in and out of
his alternate personalities throughout
he watches timid stephen grant starts to
learn about the other facets of his life
and just in case you don't know in the
comics mark is the dominant persona in
the source material he traveled to
ancient egypt and discovered a dig that
unearthed the shrine dedicated to the
god konshu after mark was badly beaten
by the person leading the dig he pledged
his life to the god so that he could get
revenge and he became his avatar moon
knight
now the show doesn't look like it's
going in this chronological direction
and instead i think that we're gonna get
a similar style to one division where
we're dropping at the deep end and left
trying to piece things together i
actually think the series will open with
us from steven's point of view and then
over the course of the series he'll
figure things out and this will lead
into him discovering everything about
mark which in turn will also fill the
audience in moonlight is gonna have to
basically deal with several different
origin stories as each of his personas
have their own one i think doing it this
way is probably the best way to go about
it now in order to talk about the next
part of the video i want to give a huge
shout out to gloria's purpose on twitter
who said that he thinks that mark was
snap and then when he was brought back
this is when he changed to stephen and
he has been him ever since this would
explain why he gets a phone call from
someone who seems surprised he's alive
and it would also explain another big
part of the teaser now during it we see
a chase in which he's in a truck being
chased by what i assume are arthur
harrow's men there is a moment where we
see followers of harrowbang before him
and in the corner you can catch the same
truck that mark later drives there are
also soldiers there with guns so it
makes sense that this is all part of the
same scene with mark fleeing in this
before they go after him at some point
he goes over a cliff and hills to his
death but we cut before we see how he
gets out of this
[Music]
now it is possible that he transforms
into his moonlight costume at this point
but typically he appears at night i
think it would be weird to have a
vigilante in broad daylight at this
point it also begs to question why he
wed it up until this moment to transform
when he could have done it at any point
in the scene before this therefore i
actually think that he'll get snap
whilst falling to the ground and that
this will be what saves his life if you
cast your mind back to the release of
avengers end game you might remember one
of the big questions floating around
about it is what happened to people who
were on a plane that got snapped when
they were brought back if they were put
in the exact same position as where the
plane was when they disappeared they'd
fall to their death but the russos
cleared this all up they said smart hulk
accounted for this and that everyone was
brought back safely on the ground which
i think would also happen with mark this
will allow steven to take over mark but
mark constantly wanting to burst out
could itch away at him and make him
suspect that something else is going on
it will also allow him to get away from
harrow and then perhaps the pair bump
into each other five years later in the
museum which is where he tells him to
embrace the chaos
embrace the chaos
[Music]
now little is known about harrow and
even in the comics he's quite an obscure
character that was basically just a mad
scientist during his face-off against
moonlight one of the priests of konshu
appeared to him when he was on the road
and it sent him visions of harrow
carrying out human experiments harrow
had won the nobel prize but there was a
lot of questions about how he managed to
achieve medical developments when it
seemed like all he had done was carry
out tests on animals however it wasn't
covered by mark that he'd been doing
these on people but the show doesn't
really seem to be going in that
direction i think that in the series we
will learn that when mark was a merc he
discovered the shrine of konchu in egypt
and then he became his vessel mark then
likely continued doing mercenary ops one
involving spying on harrow he then
witnessed things firsthand and harrow
got his followers to fight him in the
disney plus day trailer we did see a
scene in which he was surrounded by
people he'd knocked out in a street that
looks similar the one that we see harrow
in the character seems a bit confused as
to how this happened almost like he's
snapping out of something so i think
this might be him jumping to stephen
from mark if our theories are right then
the chase likely took place and this led
to him falling out the van which could
have tied into the snap and then he was
brought back five years later as stephen
he then could have bumped into harrow at
the museum which seems to be the
location a meeting is happening at due
to the statues in the background i am
interested in seeing what they could do
with harrow and i actually think they
might even combine him with other
characters ethan hawk has described him
as a david crash-esque villain that's
the leader of a cult and in order to get
this reputation i wonder if he has any
powers or abilities himself it has been
theorized for a while that he's playing
sun king and i even got so deep into
this that come the release of the
trailer i just assumed it was him big l
for kevin spoilers on that but if you
enjoy the video so far we'd massively
appreciate the thumbs up and also don't
forget to subscribe for videos like this
every day if this is your first time
here i'm paul the host of the heavy
spoilers show that brings you breakdowns
day and night now let's get into the
rest of the video also i've just
realized the day and night pun could be
a night pun with a k hey haven't that
now the internet has been full of people
pointing out amazing easter eggs such as
that and the box in the van that has von
d on it this has led many to believe
that it's actually a nod to the major
marvel villain victor von doom however
it was quickly debunked as in the next
shot you can see that the box reads von
darrellman which is the name of a
cupcake company however however however
none of you folks are as clever as i am
i actually think that in the marvel
universe victor von doom will be a
cupcake king who runs a criminal empire
selling delicious baked goods in the
comics dr doom actually got hit in the
face with a cupcake once which was
likely his super villain origin story
oh my god it's all starting to make
sense now isn't it exclusive theory
exclusive exclusive exclusive
anyway back to stephen now the character
is clearly paranoid that he becomes
someone else at night and in the teaser
we can see that he tapes up the door so
that if it's opened he'd find this torn
there's also even a ring of sand put
around his bed to show if there's been
any footprints this goes on for several
nights and we can actually tell this by
the fact that his clothes change however
another theory could be that it's all
part of the same night and the change of
clothes is because he became someone
else while steven was asleep one of the
most interesting parts of the new look
is him solving a rubik's cube which i
theorized represented his fractured
personalities all being part of one
whole the constant twisting and turning
of this could also represent how he
drops in and out of his different
personas huge shout outs to youtube user
ralph shadow for jumping off that and
saying that come the end of the season
there would be a lot of symbolism to
stephen completing it this would show
the balancing of all his personalities
and as rubik's cubes typically take a
long time to solve it could be something
that he keeps going back to doesn't take
me a long time though as i figured out
that doctor doom cupcake thing but yeah
i think that would be a great direction
to take the series now another thing
that i want to address is the creature
that moon knight fights in the bathroom
i did say that this was a jackal but
many of you commented saying that it's a
werewolf after watching the trailer over
and over and over day and night i'm
still standing strong in the theory that
it's a jackal and this is because of the
face ear shapes and also the long legs
with several joints in them i actually
think that this might be after what
steven has in the bag during the scenes
in which he's being chased though many
people think that the thing that was
stalking him in the museum was konchu
who does show up in trailer 2. i
actually think that this is the beast in
the bathroom if you look at it it has
glowing eyes whereas kunchu doesn't and
the guard carries a staff whereas this
creature is missing it thus i think it
might have been sent out by anubis to
collect whatever steven has in the bag
and he eventually ends up defeating it
in a bathroom however he did hunt
werewolves in the comics and the
character first appeared in werewolf by
night but the lack of fur and shape of
the animal makes me think it's the other
anyway hopefully you enjoy these
theories and we've been having not too
bad of a week as we actually got one
right with the latest book of boba fett
episode gonna hold on to that for the
rest of time but i'm sure you have
better ones than i've dropped in this
video so make sure you leave yours in
the comments section below we're running
a competition right now and giving away
three copies of an mc boxer of your
choice on the 3th of january all you
have to do to begin with the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the video we pick the comments at random
at the end of the month and the winners
of the last one on screen right now save
that to you then message me on twitter
at heavyspoilers if you want someone
else to watch then make sure you check
out our breakdown of the trailer which
will be linked below we also go over the
origin story of moonlight as i know some
of you are totally new to the character
so definitely go and check it out right
after this without the way thanks for
sticking through the video i've been
paul let's see in the next one take care
peace